hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to loved I am a man at least
as far as I know and as far as I've
convinced you go oh oh it's gonna be
that type of game oh I see how this is
gonna go will I teach you how to play or
not well I don't know if this little
girl wants to cooperate but sure teach
me your wise ways oh oh I did not
deserve it okay and there was something
else there alright so not that you will
control control you are wrong I just hit
control what more do you want from me
okay [ __ ] we're gonna play this game
by your rules apparently so this is a
game about choices and jump over that
pit of Barb's okay this is what I'm
assuming it's kind of like a stanley
parable type thing but this game
actually came out before the Stanley
parable this was in 2010 so I imagine
siphon a pit of Barb's I mean I know
where Oh disgusting but I thought I was
a pretty little girl Oh God
is that a platform oh ah well that's not
good oh that's probably not good or
maybe it is good hey oh okay I guess
that doesn't there's nothing he already
knows or she I don't know who they
already know that I'm disgusting Hey oh
okay Oh oops
ah no one look at what just happened the
game is oh ah so yeah I don't know what
this has to do with being loved but I
have no idea touch the statue I will
forgive you how about know when the
first time I played the Stanley parable
I said no a lot too oh jeez I'm a
disappointment but I don't wanna be ooh
ah [ __ ]
okay I got neither praise nor
admonishment so I'm gonna assume that
that was okay all righty then travel the
lower path while the lower path seems to
be filled with death oh geez I'm
disgusting ugly and a disappointment boy
I sure do feel loved oh man oh I feel
loved okay so what oh [ __ ] oh gee oh oh
I should have touched the thing oh I'm
an idiot well I'm not gonna go the lower
path this time my desire to be loved
shall not outweigh my lazy oh [ __ ]
well it's a good thing uh yeah thank you
all right god damn it I am an idiot
yeah you better spit me out the wrong
way huh oh come on why is it so hard to
do I'm just trying to thread this needle
here oh you sack of tits
I'm not doing this on purpose okay we're
gonna bite little increments of minutia
okay the problem is whenever I play
these platformer type games I'm always
in a hurry and I don't know why throw
yourself into the barbs why would you
want that that seems like a bad thing I
don't need to be loved that badly
oh you're disappointed in me who cool
what is that do I own your body or your
mind how about neither oh well I guess
uh isn't there a famous quote that you
can take my body but you'll never take
my mind or break my I don't know the
body hmm dance for me okay head I did a
little oh god I'm supposed to disobey
okay how am I supposed to dance can I
touch this is that dancing oh I don't
know
Oh things are getting really really
wonky on the colored pixelated stylings
of this rojulu okay
hey Lu you ain't gotta watch out for
this little little lu do not move
how about screw you disgusting oh that
was cheap you're cheap ah this is gonna
take forever I'm not good at that
changed oh I I take that all back on the
bed I'm the best okay do not touch the
statue what screw you that's me
Little Miss disappointment I know I know
oh god what am i wool is that coming
after me hey back off stranger danger
oh geez it's gettin it's gettin bad in
here off I slammed groin first into it
did it shake and just spit me back out
did I see that right oh yeah Oh God
race against the clock I'm not stressed
enough for this yeah look I'm really
like curious as to why oh it's a bigan
oh it's a BA come on
oh it's so far back god damn it okay get
serious here I'm trying to make jokes
I'm not actually thinking about this
properly
max yeah there I wasn't even making a
joke then I was actually trying to
contemplate the world and what's going
on in here and then I I saw a big that
one with all it wasn't even coming
towards me it was just an it was a
stationary one I panicked for nothing oh
geez he okay
soon we will see each other well I have
a funny feeling it's not gonna be a
happy real are you excited or frightened
I don't know if this makes a damn
difference
how about exploited how about
precipitant
that excited so am I good
I would is that some kink I hear in your
voice
do not fail ah [ __ ] I tripped and I fell
what can I do
do not fail ah again with the failure
how am I supposed to be able to do this
and disobey maybe I shouldn't have hit
excited maybe I should've hit frightened
I don't know I don't know if anything
would have made a difference there I
don't know like ah come on I don't know
how many endings are in this game whoo
geez whoo geez oh hey hey friends okay
goodbye see ya
see you guys I did it he did it
uh-oh why do you hate me uh I don't know
I loved you I don't think so
where will you go will you be close to
me ah oh my god I got an appointment I
beg you to stay
man you don't call someone ugly and
disgusting and then expect them to stay
but I don't this weird this is getting
weird
Oh
Oh okay that's the end then alrighty I
guess I guess in the logical sense of it
if I just left then I left
holy crap okay let me try this again and
I'm going to do it a different way I'm a
woman I'm a strong independent woman I'm
a boy oh oh we're off to a killer start
here
oh you teach you how to play how about
not
you will fail well I've already been
through that before so I think I'm gonna
be okay but this time I'm raring and
ready to obey okay jump over that hit a
buck oh oh it was a pit of Barb's he
wasn't lying to me
statue I will forgive you thank you
I'm a good boy oh that's so cool oh
that's so cool oh wow
like legitimately travel the lower path
okay I had no idea I didn't even know
that's what was happening I didn't know
that the world was devolve enlike that
oh that's legitimately really cool yeah
oh man oh this is the part that vexed me
before but I'm okay
ah oh I got vexed they vexed all over me
okay make it through make it through
yeah there we go
hey Leah little bit what the loo dare
you throw yourself into the barbs okay
this is where I kind of question things
but okay I'm a good boy that me huh-huh
it that good boy oh oh that's so cool ah
to go by the old markiplier cliche
that's so cool oh that's awesome oh
that's awesome
do I own your body or mind how about the
mind can't be this sexiness beg for me
again okay again this doesn't feel a
whole lot like love but uh what do I
know I'm just a name or by aim aim aim
or fist blah blah is like at the end of
this once I get through all this am I
gonna be the last one that gets detail
because
I seem to be like a shadow so it makes
sense that there's something else going
on here
how do I'm not moving how can I beg if I
cannot move how can I dance if I cannot
move I'm a good boy you just needed to
wait for me to load into the game you're
sure I did oh I made it
heard it okay I made it do not touch the
statue
you got a bub ready to please bub whoo
how about this statue good boy at me did
that good boy okay man this it looks a
lot nicer now that it's oh I did the
same thing again I slapped my balls
across that spike are we those are those
eyes and mouth in the walls there I'd
like to think they're not but I can't
help shake the feeling that they is
you're you're up hailey all right soon
we will see each other are you excited
or frightened I'm pretty friend then it
will only be more enjoyable for me are
you what does that mean that's that's
weird
still kinky but weird I will not fail I
will not fail
Who am was failed oh I'm an idiot I
almost failed he liked her you hear her
okay don't fail don't fail don't mess up
don't mess up okay don't mess up I'm
good I'm good I'm good I'm good I'm good
I did it I did it I did it
yeah I did it okay cool I'm so happy
that you are mine yay what are you who
are you are you a boy or a girl I'm a
good boy I'm a good boy I'm a mom
man I'm a man
Oh always oh there's more oh there's
more Oh more trials and tribulations for
me to endure what is that what is this
what does it mean what does that mean
what does that mean what does that mean
what does that mean
I don't know what that means oh I like
that I like that I like that a lot that
is cool that is legitimately cool
there's a lot of like questionable
elements about it like who was that
person who was I was that my inner
monologue was that maybe just the
thoughts inside my head
was it another situation like the park
where I made up the environment in my
own mind and the only thing I was
running away from was myself not to get
all existential about it but I'm just
kind of spitting out ideas here and
there but that was cool that was
legitimately cool okay I'll put a link
down the description below if you find
anything else in this game maybe there's
more than just two endings to this maybe
there's like a middle road there but
either way thank you all so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye
[Music]